Even as a small kid, all you ever wanted was
to climb.
Your little toes dangle off the edge of the
wooden frame of your bunk bed.
Your action figures are down below on the
carpet looking as small as ants.
Seeing the world from this height is an adrenaline
rush like no other.
But soon you outgrow your bunk bed, and you
return to the level the rest of the world
is living on.
To recapture the feeling, you ride your bike
to the park, where you climb the tallest slide
and sit perched at its peak.
The feeling of the bunk bed comes back to
you.
Up here, you’re closer to the stars and
further from your homework.
You think, “I’m never going back down.”
But soon, there is a line of children on the
slide’s ladder barking at you, calling you
a scaredy-cat, telling you to hurry up already.
A hand presses into your back and pushes you
forward.
Your small body tumbles down the slide.
Just like that, your feet are in the sand.
You’re at the same altitude as everyone
else, no longer special in your elevation.
But you’re not done.
You’re determined to go elsewhere and upward.
You start climbing trees.
First, just small ones with bumpy bark for
your feet to use like rungs on a ladder.
It feels good up there, but soon you notice
you’re not alone.
You’re sharing space with squirrels and
caterpillars.
It’s not that you’re afraid of these little
creatures, but you want to go to heights few
else ever had.
You move on to a larger tree.
This one, you even need tools to climb.
You lasso a rope around a branch and pull
yourself up.
To get even higher, you wear wide-receiver
gloves banned by the NFL so that your hands
are sticky enough to grip even the smallest
protrusions of bark.
Soon you reach the top.
Now at the highest sturdy branch of the largest
tree, you look down at the world and see it
in perfect order: you up here, them down there.
It’s beautiful.
But then a noise.
A noise too loud to have come from below.
Next to you, you see a bird.
It smugly smirks at you and flaps its wings
and flies higher, one-upping your accomplishment.
It lands on a tiny branch above you, reaching
the actual tippy top that you couldn’t reach.
And it’s then you realize that the feeling
you’re chasing isn’t just so you can look
down on the earth and scoff, but so you can
look up at the world and wonder.
So, you spend your life with your chin to
the sky, feet following your gaze.
Everything you do, every action you take,
is in the name of elevation.
You choose a career in being a union lineman.
You work the night shifts, climbing up telephone
poles.
You’re happiest farthest from the ground.
Every November, you vacation to New York,
where you run up the Empire State Building
just to taste new heights.
You submit 86 flights.
1,576 stairs.
But no matter what extremes you go to, you
feel like there is something up there still
out of reach, waiting for you.
There is only one thing that will satisfy
you.
Mt.
Everest.
If you can just reach the summit, you promise
yourself, your wife, your god, and your family
that you’ll stop straining your neck upward,
that you’ll enjoy what’s in plain sight,
that you’ll settle down and live the life
that’s right there in front you.
You begin to study for your two-month climb.
You learn about the subzero temperatures.
You learn about the journey’s physical demands
on your body.
You learn about navigation, communication,
and preparation.
But what you don’t learn about, or rather
can’t learn about, is the anomaly that awaits
you.
Unfortunately, some lessons are omitted from
books, left to be learned only by experience…and
by that time…I’m afraid it’ll be much
too late in the lecture to get a passing grade.
The day comes, and you begin your mission
to the mountain’s peak.
There’s something otherworldly about it.
The way you move up this mountain…it isn’t
just a matter of labor.
There’s a spirituality within the journey.
You feel as if you are floating, being pushed
toward the heavens by some generous being
behind you.
But what is it that actually pushes you upward?
Could it be as simple an answer as willpower?
Determination?
Skill?
No.
You’ve felt those before.
And while they have surely powered many men
to do great things, this force is different.
It is not so much that it is pushing you forward…it
is more like it is pulling you up…or rather…luring
you in.
You’re amazed at how effortless the journey
is.
At least, that is, up until now.
Upon reaching the 8,000-meter mark, also known
as the “Death Zone,” you begin to feel
uneasy.
No longer is each step light and graceful,
now it feels like your boots are filled with
cement.
You could swear your backpack is full of bricks.
For a moment, you think you have lost your
beanie and gloves, because your ears and fingers
are ice cold.
The journey suddenly becomes long and grueling.
Dangerous and difficult.
You use every muscle in your body to climb
this thing.
You have to.
You use every bit of mental concentration
just to keep moving.
You have to.
But why?
Why now?
Could it be as simple an answer as exhaustion?
Accumulated fatigue?
How could it be?
You’ve prepared as much as humanly possible.
Not just in your training, but in your life.
You were meant for this moment, but now the
moment is refusing your embrace.
Nothing you could have done could have prepared
you for this.
An amorphous feeling settles in your gut.
You don’t understand it entirely, but you
anticipate something bad is about to happen,
and it is at this moment that you wish you
wouldn’t have traveled alone.
You wish you had a partner to reassure you
that everything would be okay.
You wish you had someone a few steps in front
encouraging you forward.
You stop and stare ahead and imagine it.
You imagine a friend to struggle with, to
laugh with, to succeed with.
And then suddenly, you don’t have to imagine
any longer.
You see someone…
but how?
Last you heard, you were the only one to be
traveling this way.
Could it be an illusion?
You squint harder and harder trying to make
sense of what you’re actually seeing.
A human.
Or at least, a humanlike thing.
It is wearing all white mountaineering clothes
and boots.
There is something about the clothes and boots
that makes you think they might not even be
clothes or boots at all, but more like an
extension of flesh.
Although they appear to be made of traditional
clothing materials, they seem to be one with
the figure’s body.
And the figure’s body seems to be one with
the mountain.
While you are on a mountain thousands of miles
away from your family, this…thing is at
home.
But what is it?
You squint through specs of snow splashing
across your vision.
It seems about average human height and average
human weight.
Could it be simply an average-sized human?
You want to make this conclusion with your
mind, but your eyes won’t let you.
At this distance, it is still just a figure.
But as he approaches you, and the possibility
of a companion sinks in, you become more optimistic,
and you think maybe this figure can be a friend.
Little do you know, you have just met a mountain
climbers’ biggest foe.
Meet SCP-1529.
You notice its black goggles, and then, strangely
enough, you can’t stop noticing them.
You find it impossible to break eye contact
with it.
You are physically unable to turn away.
Not only that, but you do not have any desire
to turn away either.
You are drawn into its gaze.
And you are happy to be there.
For the first time in your entire life, you
are content with where you are at.
You no longer care about climbing Mt.
Everest.
You strive no longer for great physical or
metaphorical heights.
You are more than okay with where you are
at right here, right now.
And now you begin to feel very warm and comfortable,
and you have a sudden urge to sit down and
relax for a while.
The unhurried pace of your movements matches
the stoned swaying seen at a reggae concert.
You sit down and rock back and forth.
You are at peace in this idleness, almost
in a sedated state of consciousness.
You misinterpret the signs of this dangerous
anomaly as a sign of personal growth.
You believe wholeheartedly that this is who
you are now and that this is who you were
always meant to be.
With newfound peace, you settle into the snow.
You embrace the moment.
And that’s when it gets even worse.
SCP-1529 moves toward you, navigating the
mountain with ease, using just his hands and
feet, no gear needed.
As its arrival looms, there is nothing you
can do but wait.
But what exactly are you waiting for?
What’s going on?
Where did this thing come from?
Well, you wouldn’t be the first to ask.
L, the subject of Incident 1529-1, questioned
this himself.
L was reportedly killed during an encounter
with SCP-1529 when it abruptly became active
shortly after he had reached the mountain's
summit.
However, L was eventually found alive when
another team reached his position nearly two
days later and removed him safely from the
mountain.
He required fingertip and toe amputations
due to frostbite but otherwise made a full
recovery.
While still in the hospital, an agent of The
Foundation was able to ask him questions and
figure out what he had experienced.
It was a difficult time for L, but it was
an exciting time for The Foundation.
From what they previously understood of SCP-1529,
they never thought they would ever hear the
truth straight from its victim’s mouth.
Until then, it was only ever told through
their autopsy.
L was on his way down the mountain.
He was proud and excited having reached the
top and accomplished his life’s goal, but
he understood the trek back was no easier,
and that if he didn’t stay focused, he would
end up dead like so many others.
He noticed his hood was off, and he stopped
to adjust it.
No big deal.
Just a quick fix.
Little did L know, it would lead to such hardships.
During his wardrobe malfunction, his group
made their way about six meters ahead of him.
And it was then, standing in his newfound
loneliness, that he saw SCP-1529 coming over
the ridge.
L was a jovial fellow.
His impulse wasn’t to fear the figure.
Instead, he shouted and waved, assuming the
figure to be another climber left behind by
his mates.
Suddenly, it looked right at him.
And that’s when it started to happen.
L felt happy and relieved.
It was like all the pain and the soreness
and the chill were gone.
No longer did he have blisters on his feet.
He could feel his toes again.
It was like he was back home in front of the
fireplace.
It was as if the journey was complete, and
his efforts had been rewarded.
L no longer minded the mission back down.
He felt perfectly fine where he was.
But even still, while his body was content,
his gut didn’t trust the feeling.
Something was off.
Why would L go all this way only to become
complacent?
He kept thinking.
He kept fighting the urges to relax, to succumb
to supposed feelings of warmth.
He knew the stories of men who felt similar
misleading sensations.
When your body starts to cool down to an extreme
degree, your blood vessels dilate, and you
start to feel like you’re actually warming
up.
In these instances, people often tear off
their clothes because they feel like they
are burning up and need to cool down.
Next thing they know, they’re naked and
frozen to death.
L would not go like that.
He had too much pride.
He tried to shrug off the feeling of warmth,
but before he even could…it was stripped
from him.
As SCP-1529 got closer, suddenly, all of the
heat and comfort L had experienced was gone.
He was cold.
Colder than he had ever been before.
His fingers and face no longer had feeling.
His lips peeled, snapped, and cracked.
They were frozen.
His legs cramped up.
He buckled at the knees and dropped to the
snow.
He tried to yell for help, but all that came
out was a soft and pathetic whisper.
SCP-1529 grabbed L’s shoulders and pulled
him toward its face.
L looked into his goggles, having no other
choice.
He saw images in the lenses.
And suddenly it was as if L was watching a
film, or rather brief vignettes.
He saw people in hot tubs relaxing.
A woman curled up by an open fire.
A couple sunbathing on the beach.
L recognized all these warm and happy people.
They were people he had seen on the way up
the mountain but not the way down.
It only took a moment for L to realize they
were people who had fallen to SCP-1529.
It was then that L knew he had to resist.
But SCP-1529 doesn’t take well to defiance.
The images in the goggles changed from happy
to horror.
The same people were now laying in the snow,
half-dead.
L couldn’t manage to look at it for another
second.
He balled his fist with whatever strength
God was willing to lend him, he tried to strike
SCP-1529 in the goggles.
His arm moved slowly at first, like a punch
in a dream.
It was moving as if the air it traveled through
was thick Jell-O. Suddenly, it snapped into
full speed and drilled SCP-1529 square in
the center of his goggles, ultimately leading
to L’s rescue.
But this is no princess movie.
Not everyone is so lucky to be rescued.
This brings us back to you.
Yes, you.
Wait, you didn’t think that brief deviation
from 2nd person would last forever, did you?
So, where were we?
Or should I say, where were you?
Oh, yes.
You’re sitting in the snow patiently waiting
for SCP-1529 to kill you.
And as you wait for its arrival, you think
back to the survival lessons that L taught
you.
Now, you see why I suddenly changed to 3rd
person earlier?
You needed that information so you can call
back on it for your third and final act.
Isn’t that nice?
Psh, who says omniscient narrators can’t
also be benevolent?
So, you’re thinking of L and how he punched
SCP-1529, and you’re thinking you’ll do
the same.
But what you can learn from L, so SCP-1529
may have learned as well.
Would such a threatening creature ever be
defeated in the same way twice?
You notice that its goggles have been repaired,
and you intend on cracking them open again
like an egg.
But your fist won’t close.
Your arm won’t raise.
You keep trying to start up your strength
like an old pick-up truck.
Nothing.
Your luck eludes you.
You feel helpless.
And so, you sit in the snow and wait.
You can’t ball up your fingers into fists,
but you can bring one palm to the other and
pray.
You pray for help from your god above.
Your prayers, however, are misguided.
Yes, there is help above.
But it’s not a god that’s watching over
you, but rather The Foundation’s aerial
surveillance.
A well-oiled system of spyware born out of
necessity, designed after the incident known
as SCP-1529-2.
SCP-1529-2 occurred when an agent, located
in a permanent facility in China, observed
SCP-1529 through a telescope while it was
active near the summit of the mountain.
That day, SCP-1529 looked directly into the
telescope.
The agent immediately reported symptoms consistent
with an SCP-1529 encounter and reported that
SCP-1529 had begun descending the mountain
in the direction of the permanent facility.
Similar to the stories on the mountain, the
agent, too, was unable to pull himself away
from the telescope.
After 17 minutes under the spell of SCP-1529,
he was rushed to the facility sickbay and
found to have signs of frostbite in the fingers
and toes, despite having remained indoors
for the duration of the encounter.
The Foundation then had to rethink its approach
to surveilling SCP-1529.
When SCP-1529 is active, surveillance is now
conducted by means of an automatic telescope
with a video feed playing at seven seconds
delay to avoid a repeat of Incident 1529-2.
When necessary and safe, additional observation
is done by way of helicopter and airplane.
Furthermore, the bodies of any hikers who
encounter SCP-1529 are removed from the mountain
as soon as possible for autopsy and disposal.
The Foundation attributes all SCP-1529-related
casualties to natural causes relating to altitude
sickness and hypothermia.
Any survivors or witnesses are debriefed and
administered a Class-B amnestic.
And for even further safety measures, Mobile
Task Force Psi-29029, also known as "Alpine
Echo", remains on standby at all times at
the Foundation monitoring station, in a pressurized
environment acclimatized to 7,900 meters above
sea level.
In the event that a recurrence of Incident
1529-1 occurs, Alpine Echo deploys to the
mountain by helicopter.
And so, by the grace of The Foundation you
will be saved.
Although sitting helplessly in the snow you
may feel your current state of existence can
best be described by the phrase dead meat,
you are more than likely to be saved than
slaughtered.
Even still, there is no comfort in the future.
On the mountain, right here, right now, you
are looking up and locking eyes with SCP-1529.
Your whole life has come to this moment.
All you ever wanted as a child was to climb
the highest heights.
Aspiring upward has brought you so many good
things.
Adventures.
Financial stability.
Respect.
Everything you have in your life is from the
simple fact that you did not settle for what
you had but strived for what was above you.
But now, this same impulse has gotten you
in a world of trouble.
Had you just looked at where you were instead
of where you wanted to be, you would have
been okay.
If you just felt the snow beneath your feet
you would have been okay.
But instead, you looked up, how you always
did.
You looked up toward the goal and away from
the present.
And look where it has led you.
The message of this story is clear, but if
for some reason we resist the lesson passed
down from one generation of thinkers to the
next, SCP-1529 is out there, waiting for us
to turn over our shoulder and look back or
tilt our chin and look up.
And at that point, it will force the moral
on you again, giving you no other option but
to experience its wrath: right here, right
now.
Now go check out “Frozen Bodies on Everest
are ALIVE - SCP-5140” and “SCP-096 Killed
My Friend” for more high-altitude horrors!